solve for y and check your solution 20
minus 7y is equal to 6y minus 6 so what
I really want to just do is isolate all
of the Y's on one side of this equation
and then if there's some coefficient in
front of it I can divide both sides by
that coefficient and I could isolate the
Y on either the left side or the right
side of the equation actually let me do
it both ways
so first let's it looks like it'll be a
little bit simple if I isolate it on the
right hand side and I'll show you that
in a second so if I want to put all of
the Y's on the right-hand side how could
I get rid of the Y's on the left-hand
side well haven't I have a minus 7y or
you could use the negative 7y i can add
7y to both sides of this equation so I'm
just adding 7y to both sides then the
left-hand side of the equation we have
20 minus 7y plus 7y those are going to
cancel out you're going to be just left
with 20 and on the right-hand side of
the equation you're going to have six Y
plus 7y which is 13 y and then you have
your minus 6 and I want only Y's or
multiples of y's on the right-hand side
of the equation so I need to get rid of
this this knit -6 over here so let's add
6 to both sides of this equation let's
add 6 and then on the on the right-hand
side of 13 Y minus 6 plus 6 that's just
13 y got rid of the minus 6 and have 20
plus 6 so that is 26 so I get 26 is
equal to 13 y I've isolated the Y on the
right-hand side although it's being
multiplied by 13 so if I just want a Y
on the right hand side or 1y on the
right hand side I can divide both sides
by 13 or the equivalent statement would
be to multiply both sides by 1 over 13
same thing so let's divide both sides of
this equation by 13 on the right hand
side 13 times y divided by 13 well
that's just going to be Y so this is
just Y and then 26 divided by 13 that is
2 so our solution we got is y is equal
to 2 now I want to take a step back why
did I say it would be a little bit
easier to add to put the Y's on the
right-hand side of the equation well
because that's why I got a positive
coefficient on in terms of why I got 13
why if I had subtracted 6 Y from both
sides that I've got a negative 13 on the
left-hand side which would have been a
legitimate thing to do let me just show
you what I'm talking about so I could
have done the problem this way 20 do
that in a different color I could have
said 20 let me just rewrite it 20 minus
7y is equal to 6y minus 6 now let me
just subtract 6 Y from both sides so
minus 6y or negative 6y from both sides
the left hand side over here is 20 minus
13 why the right hand side I got rid of
that 6y I just have the minus 6 here or
it's just a negative 6 now and now I can
subtract 20 from both sides to isolate
the Y's on the left hand side so I am
subtracting 20 from both sides I'm doing
that to get rid of this 20 and so on the
left hand side i have a negative 13y and
on the right hand side I have a negative
I have a negative 26 now I want to
divide both sides of this equation by
negative 13 so I want to divide both
sides of this equation by negative 13
and what do I get negative 13 times
something divided by negative 13 is just
that something I just go to Y and then
negative 26 divided by negative 13 is 2
so I did it two different ways
over here are isolated the Y's on the
left-hand side over here I did on the
right-hand side
I picked the right-hand side first so
that everything stays positive but this
is an equally valid way to do it now the
last thing I want to do is just make
sure that we got the right answer
we should probably feel pretty
comfortable we got the same answer doing
it two different ways but let's actually
check it let's put y equal to back into
the equation and verify that we get the
Equality so we have 20 minus 7y is 2 so
7 times 2 should be equal to 6 times 2 6
times 2 minus 6 so 20 this should be 20
minus 14 you might want to do
multiplication first order of operations
so this is 20 minus 14 should be equal
to 6 times 2 is 12 minus 6 20 minus 14
is 6
12 minus 6 is 6 6 is indeed equal to 6
so it all checks out